chris cornell to me is one of the
greatest voices
there ever was in rock and roll i mean
hands down that guy
could sing his ass off
[Music]
i would have loved to have seen
soundgarden in concert and
although i never got to see him in
concert
every time he was on he sang if the song
refused to shine
[Music]
you would do cover versions didn't
matter whatever he sang it was just
perfect and moving and you know you just
wanted to weep
there would still be me
when he would come in and do black hole
son won't you come
in hell
[Music]
won't you
[Music]
he had such an effect on me that for
like five days
afterwards i'm walking around the house
you know black hole
sun at lunch you come and
and and it would drive my wife insane
she goes oh you had chris cornell on huh
yeah yeah
that's what happened black hole son did
you think that was a great version fred
yes i did i mean i i think he's got one
of the i do agree i think he's got one
of the greatest voices in rock do you
feel he was a good guitar player he's a
great guitar player he's a great
musician period he's one of those
charismatic guys that would walk into
the studio
and i just say like there's a rock star
you know he looked like a rock star he
sang like a rock star
but he also had a lot of humility he was
a humble man you won two grammys right
yeah did that mean anything to you are
you one of those guys let me see
a guy who's like you know you know a big
deal it does more now
um it was a little the same thing back
then did you show up to the grammys yeah
well you did it
we we said thank you um you know it was
a great moment for me because
a guy who's my hero who's al green ended
up giving away the award for like best
metal performance because they [ __ ] up
like who the presenters were going to be
at the last second
and the best metal performance is
spoon man so
that was like one of the few fan moments
i've had but
you know we're all standing there as a
band sort of feeling like we got to look
like we don't care
right yeah do we care or not i'm not
really sure you have to calculate
we really have to calculate you know is
it cool for our fans to see us caring
that much
yeah or is it better to say you know
this this really sucks
um you know what i i don't think it
sucked i think it's great that i
won two grammys he was just fantastic
great guest
a great singer very missed very missed
you may
say i'm a dreamer
[Music]
but i'm not the only one
maybe one day you will join us
in the world
[Music]
we'll live as one
you